- [Radio Officer] Request to
stay clear from our passage
in accordance with the
position regulations, over.
- [Reporter] Off the
coast of the Philippines,
clashes with China have
become a common occurrence,
which Philippine officials call
- A David versus Goliath situation.
- The external security environment
is becoming more complex.
It is becoming more unpredictable.
- [Reporter] The rising tensions
between the two countries
have major implications
for the United States
and have opened the door
for a greater U.S. military
presence in the Philippines.
- We're a mutual defense treaty partner,
and we will come to the
aid of the Philippines
if they're attacked.
It's as simple as that.
- [Reporter] Here's what's
happening in the Philippines
and why the country is
becoming increasingly important
to global superpowers, big
players in the Pacific,
and smaller neighbors
in the South China Sea.
First, let's talk superpowers.
The Philippines is part of an arc
of U.S. allies and partners
that Washington is leaning
on for help countering China.
To its west is the South China Sea,
a massive global shipping lane
that Beijing claims almost all of.
To the north is the
democratic island of Taiwan,
a key western trading partner
that China has threatened
to take by force.
To learn more
about the Philippines'
growing strategic importance,
we traveled there in April,
during the largest-ever exercises
between the U.S. and
Philippine militaries.
- [Military Officer] Stinger loads coming!
(rocket fires)
- [Reporter] Stingers,
(rocket roars)
Patriots,
and HIMARS,
(rocket roars)
some of America's most powerful weapons,
engaged in a target practice
over the South China Sea,
a body of water that China
has steadily moved to control.
(helicopters whirring)
Up north, troops conducted
air assaults from a Navy ship
flying to islands just
100 miles from Taiwan,
the world's leading producer
of advanced semiconductors,
which China has threatened
to take by force.
- We don't want a war with China.
Nobody wants that.
That said, that doesn't
distract me from doing my job.
That's my job.
- Is the U.S. prepared to fight?
- Absolutely, and that's
what we're doing here.
(weapon fires)
(military cheers)
- [Reporter] The Philippines
has moved closer to the United States
under its new President,
Ferdinand Marcos Jr.
- This is the first time
a president has actually
attended a major live fire event.
- So this year was different.
- Yes, this year was
significantly different.
- [Reporter] The shift comes
after Marcos's predecessor,
Rodrigo Duterte,
tried to steer the
country closer to Beijing.
- I want to be friend to China.
- [Reporter] Despite his efforts,
China didn't back off of its claims
near the Philippine coast,
and has only ramped up its show of force.
How concerned are you
with the continued provocation from China?
- As concerned as you could possibly be.
- [Reporter] For help
defending its sovereignty,
Manila struck a major base
deal with Washington this year,
increasing U.S. access
to Philippine military
bases across the country
from five to nine.
And officials say they
are continuing a dialogue
about adding even more.
The developments have
angered officials in Beijing,
who have have said that China opposes
the wanton expansion of military alliances
and have accused the U.S.
of trying to contain China.
China's embassy in Manila didn't respond
to requests for comment for this story.
Both China and the U.S.
are major trading partners
to the Philippines.
But this year, Manila and
Washington have taken steps
to boost economic cooperation,
with the U.S. pledging to invest
in everything from 5G networks
to critical mineral production
throughout the country.
- These countries have to
maintain their sovereignty.
It's important to them;
it's important to us.
We want to help them do it.
- [Reporter] The Philippines
is also moving closer
to U.S. allies in the Pacific,
like Australia, Japan, and South Korea.
(cameras clicking)
Some of those countries
have also trained
alongside Filipino troops,
and with Marcos in charge,
their leaders have made moves
to improve ties with Manila.
- This elevation is an important symbol
of the strength of our relationship
and our shared commitment
to do more together.
- [Reporter] These Pacific
powers, also alarmed
by China's growing
militarization of the region,
recognize that the Philippines
is on the front lines
in the effort to push back on Beijing.
- China's distorting the
story to fit its own ends.
- [Reporter] China has made
expansive maritime claims
using this nine-dash line,
which is believed to be based
on maps used by the
Republic of China in 1947.
Within those lines,
Beijing has seized control
of reefs and islands
and turned them into military outposts.
To maintain control,
Chinese ships routinely
harass Philippine vessels
with water cannons, signs,
and military-grade lasers.
(protestors chanting)
- [Reporter] China's actions
have angered much of the population,
and under Marcos, the Philippines
has been pushing back.
The Coast Guard has adopted a new strategy
of publicizing encounters
with Chinese ships
and calling out Beijing
for not abiding by an international ruling
that invalidated China's
nine-dash line claims.
- It just goes to show that the Chinese
have always been ignoring
the international law.
- [Reporter] Beijing has
ignored the international ruling
and has said that its maneuvers
are legal and justified.
Now, Pacific powers
like Australia and Japan
are planning to conduct joint
patrols with the Philippines
to up the pressure on
Beijing and keep the waters
that are vital to their
economies and national security
open and free.
- To have friends like
you and partners like you,
and that is very gratifying,
and encourages us to
continue down that path.
- [Reporter] But the Philippines itself
is still facing major challenges
when it comes to protecting its borders
and helping its people.
Hello, yes.
- Okay.
- [Reporter] The economy has been growing,
with the World Bank
forecasting 6% growth in 2023.
And while the country has been blessed
with a wealth of natural resources
and a young and growing population,
millions of people leave to work abroad.
More than 15% of the
population lives in poverty
and rising prices have hit hard.
Inflation for rice, the
country's number one food staple,
surged to 8.7% this summer,
prompting the government
to impose price caps.
And fish stocks, another food
staple, have been declining.
The country is also plagued
by its small number of military assets,
its frail power grids,
and its congested roads.
It would be faster if you walked, no?
- Faster this way, ma'am.
- [Reporter] It's also racing
to explore new sources of energy,
since its main gas field, Malampaya,
is expected to run out within a decade.
Reed Bank, a site seen as
key to unlocking more energy,
is at the center of a dispute with China.
- For the Filipino
people, it's very simple.
That is ours.
- [Reporter] Victor
Dindo Manhit runs polling
on issues like China's actions
in the South China Sea.
He says a lot of these
challenges help illustrate
why the Filipino people
support the country
moving closer to the United
States and its allies.
- There are a lot of challenges,
and people will say,
and I agree with them,
"We lost time," but for
me it's not too late.
We are now moving towards to
work with other countries,
and that's what we all need here.
But these countries are ready
to work with the Philippines.
(traffic rumbling softly)
(horn honks)